I had a very emotional morning,
and I was craving a little pick me up drink,
since I've been thinking about making horchata for the last few days,
I decided to just make it today.
I soaked my rice in some water with cinnamon
for about four to five hours
while I got started on making some condensed milk.
Combine milk and sugar, put that on the stove,
and then made some evaporated milk by just boiling off some milk.
After about 45 minutes, my condensed milk was done,
so I strained it and put that in the fridge to thicken.
Done to straining all the skin off my evaporated milk
before letting that cool as well.
While those were cooling in the fridge,
I poured my rice, water,
and a little bit of the cinnamon into my blender.
I blended that for about five minutes before straining that as well,
making sure I get all the liquid out before adding that to a big jug.
Putting my condensed milk,
my evaporated milk, and about another two cups of water to thin it out.
I gave that a really good stir,
and I was finally done. Filled up my glass with some ice,
added my horchata, a dash of cinnamon,
and this was so divine and hit the spot.